pour karim zéribi oui parce que en fait
j'essaye de tirer un bilan de la
politique ont amené jusqu'à présent vrai
est ce que la politique que l'on mène
qui est soi-disant une politique de
répression jeudi soit disant parce que
je connais un peu les quartiers la
répression excusez moi mais de quelle
est en théorie plus que dans la pratique
c'est quand même les mecs qui font les
réseaux de cannabis qui tiennent lé
quartier aujourd'hui mettre la banque
est devant le quartier ils sont
tranquilles et long termes mêmes de
mettre les produits en soldes à un
moment donné non mais c'est une réalité
doc c'est dramatique la situation est
dramatique des gamins qui sortent de
l'école à 15 ans qui sont désocialisées
comprend comme guetteur dans les
quartiers finalement il fume n'importe
quoi s'est coupé avec du pneu du
caoutchouc donc sur la santé publique
c'est un désastre
2 sur la répression ça ne porte pas si
paris trois mois je vis dans une ville
comme marseille
on en parle beaucoup mais je suis sûr
qu'en région parisienne ont fait moins
de pub autour et des règlements de
comptes de gamins de plus en plus jeunes
qui viennent des sommes astronomiques
alors là pour le coup si les sommes des
footballeurs mais pas me taper dans un
ballon donc en prenant la kalach
donc c'est insupportable et moi je dis
que finalement la politique que l'on
mène n'a que des effets négatifs c'est
un échec total
donc qu'est ce que je propose qu'un
jeudi pour je pense qu'à des pays des
nations civilisées des grandes nations
qui ont légalisé le cannabis est ce
qu'on a le plus de fumeurs la réponse
est non est ce qu'on trouve plus de
moyens pour faire de la prévention
prévention qu'on ne fait pas chez nous
la réponse est oui
est ce qu'à un moment donné on lutte eux
plus contre les méfaits sur le terre de
la santé publique oui parce que les gars
quand on a des coffee shops et fumeux
plus du caoutchouc il filme donc du vrai
qu'un ami ce qui n'est pas coupée et
compagnie et donc qu'on peut faire à la
fois des campagnes de prévention pour
les gamins à la fois interdit aussi aux
mineurs à la fois faire en sorte qu'ils
aient de l'argent qui rentre dans les
caisses de l'état permettez moi d
économie ce qu'on fait des études ces
deux milliards et demi par an le
business du cannabis qui échappe et qui
va dans les mêmes des caïds à un moment
donné je me dis est ce que pendant cinq
ans on peut pas mener une action
expérimentale et autour d'expériences 5
après plus de fumeurs plus de mes cmh et
hop on revient à la politique de
répression
pourquoi on est d'un dédain des
approches qui sont univoques soit on est
pour son est content mais c'est pas tout
le temps on peut faire ça un temps donné
faire des analyses de des retours
d'expérience et ensuite si ça fonctionne
on continue si ça fonctionne pas oui si
c'est pire aujourd'hui on revient une
politique et celle d'aujourd'hui mais au
jeu
oui je ne peux pas être pour le statu
quo à partir du moment où tout ce que
nous faisons n'indique pas le phénomène
les jeunes fument de plus en plus jeunes
et à des désastres sur la santé publique
des désastres par les règlements de
compte des voyoucratie qui tiennent des
quartiers entiers des gens qui sont pris
en otage ça bon je peux plus l'accepter
mais karim ou de faire aussi bien courir
pardon je j'ai suivi ton raison il ya
une chose qui est totalement incohérent
tu peux pas tester ce genre de choses à
bras mais non basso pas league
oui non mais non tu peux pas légaliser
la consommation du cannabis constater
que c'est un échec et ensuite
l'interdire pourquoi mais je te demande
pardon tu fais très concrètement comment
ça commence mais comment tu fais tes
j'ai une paire dit je ferme les civils
dans certains pays alors ça a donné quoi
ensuite
mais c'est pas que ça a donné quoi c'est
qu'on a la capacité physique sont mal
payés un peu le masque disait si tu te
mets des problèmes loyal à la norme ne
traduit pas voilà parce qu'en fait on
pas revenir en arrière
voilà alors rose j'ai du mal avec un
état qui filme philosophiquement serait
pour de la drogue a pas de drogues dures
ya pas de drogues douces ya juste la
drogue
effectivement c'est un échec notre
passion et notre système de sanctions
peut-être parce qu'il faudrait et
sanctionner les trafics mais aussi
sanctionner les consommateurs parce que
il y à du trafic parce qu'il ya des
consommateurs donc effectivement notre
politique elle est assez faible
et puis il a rappelé un désastre pour
notre jeunesse je ne suis pas sûr que
les éduquer au cannabis ça face de nous
une meilleure jeunesse et à est alors
dit aux mineurs c'est pas si aujourd'hui
elle interdit ce sera autorisé gonzalo
et puis pour prendre un exemple qui est
européen que soit la belgique ou les
pays-bas
on a effectivement légaliser le cannabis
en revanche on a les phénomènes de ce
qu'on appelle la moc roma fia qui en
fait la mafia marocaine où les gens qui
ne peuvent plus d'îles et du cannabis
ont commencé à dix les de la drogue qui
avec des réseaux en fait aux qui
viennent d'amérique latine et c'est de
pire en pire c'est à dire que c'est des
règlements de comptes qui ont augmenté
ces on a on a eu en fait ce qui était
des trafics locaux
c'est devenu une mafia à grande échelle
et puis enfin pour pour pour terminer
j'ai péché du coup j'ai perdu mon idée
pour terminer non du tout je ne suis pas
pour les droits des non pardon non pour
terminer
je pense que le principal le principal
vecteur ce serait se serait l'éducation
aujourd'hui on a fait des on a fait de
grandes avancées contre la la la la
consommation en fait de du vin de
l'alcool et autres pour le pont pour la
jeunesse je pense qu'on fait pas
suffisamment pour la drogue parce que
justement on donne une image récréatif
de la drogue alors qu'on interdise de
facilement l'alcool je pense qu'on
devrait beaucoup plus éduquer notre
jeunesse aux dangers du cannabis du
mauvais de le docteur oui juste une
précision quand ma femme m'a cassé le
rétro c'est moi qui ai mal garé la
voiture mais je reconnais moi madame est
il bien la maison ce soir je le remets
bien et demain il rentrera gentiment
voilà donc bon c'est de ma faute et je
m'excuse auprès de la france alors non
je suis contre la légalisation du
cannabis
j'ai travaillé à maison blanche en
psychiatrie quand j'étais interne et si
vous regardez il y avait de l'alcool
comment jongler alors oui et donc c'est
un hôpital psychiatrique et quasiment
100 % des patients schizophrènes lourd
fumer du cannabis et souvent c'est un
mode d'entrée dans la psychiatrie et
j'ai eu la chance de gagner une émission
sur europe 1 et on a un invité chaque
jour un expert qui vient et on a le
neurologue qui nous explique en soin
intensif de neurologie lorsqu'un patient
fait un avc un des tests qui font
systématiquement ses recherches de
cannabis on le sait pas mais le cannabis
peut entraîner des avc des accidents
vasculaires cérébraux par un spasme
d'une artère est donc pour des raisons
de santé publique
moi je suis plutôt content maintenant
karim a raison on a une vision très
hypocrite
on est en train de se débrider un petit
peu avec le cannabis thérapeutique nous
les médecins simple des prescripteurs de
drogue et donc on sait semblant de pas
comprendre alors que là en train
d'ouvrir une brèche donc peut-être que
la société doit évoluer mais pour les
allégations du cannabis récréatif pour
le mans je suis contre le loup
rapidement alors je suis d'accord avec
mon voisin de droite c'est jimmy
j'ai mis mon coeur est à gauche mais
c'est pas la peine de le préciser je
crois qu'on avait compris
alors moi je pense que déjà le
raisonnement le raisonnement de ce
direct n'arrive pas à réguler quelque
chose il faut légaliser
je pense que c'est pas un bon
raisonnement pas ce que ça veut dire
qu'on quelque part on a échoué est donc
bon ou est-ce qu'on commence lorsqu'on
s'arrête on n'arrive pas à réguler le
deal de crack
est-ce qu'on légalise donc je pose déjà
la question est ce que c'est une bonne
façon de voir les choses de se dire que
parce qu'on échoue on doit permettre aux
jeunes de fumer du cannabis fumé du
cannabis c'est aussi des jeunes qui
souvent ne vont plus en cours ça il ya
une asthénie très important qui a une
grosse fatigue comme ça et je demanderai
simplement à tous les gens qui sont ici
ont peut-être des ados est ce qu'ils ont
envie de voir leurs ados rentrer à la
maison avec un joint à la marche moi
j'ai des ados et bien franchement moi je
pose la question parce que moi
personnellement je serais plutôt meurtri
de voir ma fille rentrer avec un joint à
la bouche
votre la sison temps même si elle a 16
ans à merde elle en a c'est vrai en plus
voyez vous il n'y a sûrement pas et je
pense que franchement ça doit faire
drôle accaparant devoir boissons bon
sens gamin avec la joie et avec tout ce
que ça enchaîne derrière il faut aller
dans la poche et maintenant j'ai
longtemps hésité sur cette question mais
les arguments qu'elle a résumé karim
m'ont convaincu non seulement la
répression ne donne rien mais nous
sommes les champions d'europe de la
consommation de cannabis est ensuite
faut pas se mentir
la situation à tel point que la seule
manière de reprendre le contrôle ça peut
pas être une voie policière ça peut pas
être la voie de la répression ça peut
être la voix de l'égalisation pour
essayer de remettre la main sur le
trafic ça fait vivre des centaines de
milliers de personnes s'est en fait des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
transitent c'est hors de contrôle on n'y
arrivera pas par les voies
traditionnelles voilà on va regarder son
boss des téléspectateurs tient alors
pour à 68 pour sow est contre à 32% là
vous êtes dans le vrai voilà là autour
de la table et oui pour à 68%
c'est vrai que calme vous avez bien
ouvert le débat